ah
[Música]
en colombia en la pandemia de kobe 19 ha
agudizado algunas de sus principales
problemáticas la pobreza y las
desigualdades a raíz de la crisis
sanitaria que deja casi 3 millones de
contagios en el último año la pobreza
monetaria creció 68 puntos afectando al
42 5% de sus habitantes ya son 21
millones de colombianos en situación de
pobreza en un país de 50 millones de
habitantes pero también se incrementó la
pobreza extrema en el país con 7 a 5
millones de personas padeciendo
necesidades extremas según los últimos
datos del departamento administrativo
nacional de estadísticas en este
contexto la draconiana subida de
impuestos con el fallido proyecto de
reforma tributaria del presidente iván
duque que afectaría principalmente a las
clases medias y bajas del país ha
provocado masivas movilizaciones que se
vienen sucediendo desde el pasado 28 de
abril miles de colombianos han salido a
las calles y continúan haciéndolo a
pesar de la retirada de la reforma para
exigirle al gobierno mejores
oportunidades laborales el reparto de la
riqueza y un futuro digno
[Música]
la tasa de pobreza en honduras un país
de 9.5 millones de habitantes aumentó de
manera considerable de 59.3 por ciento
en el 2019 a un 70% en el 2020 a raíz de
la pandemia del cob y 19 y el impacto de
los huracanes está ello está en el país
en un último estudio la universidad
nacional autónoma de honduras propuso al
gobierno iniciar un programa de
vacunación masiva contra el kobe 19 y de
esa manera empezar poco a poco con la
reactivación de la economía el gobierno
a su vez ha implementado algunos
programas de ayuda social como por
ejemplo inyectar recursos al agro y al
café así como el apoyo a pequeños
emprendedores sin embargo la mayor
noticia viene de norteamérica después de
que el presidente de los eeuu joe biden
ha pedido al congreso una inyección
económica de 861 millones de dólares a
los países del triángulo del norte
conformados por honduras el salvador y
guatemala
[Música]
si bien panamá tiene uno de los mayores
ingresos per cápita en la región también
es cierto que es uno de los países con
mayor desigualdad dentro del continente
americano y en donde la pandemia también
ha agudizado la situación de los más
vulnerables por ejemplo en el mismo la
pobreza se incrementó de 12% a casi 15%
y pudo haber sobrepasado el 20 por
ciento según el más reciente informe del
banco mundial que atribuye al plan de
ayuda gubernamental que se haya frenado
ese aumento el impacto en el ingreso de
las familias también se ha medido por el
índice de desempleo que pasó de 7% en
2019 a casi el triple 18.5 por ciento en
2020 con todo este panorama el programa
de naciones unidas para el desarrollo
argumenta que el 90% de los afectados se
encuentran en las zonas rurales y
específicamente en las zonas indígenas
del país que carecen de menor acceso a
servicios básicos y oportunidades
laborales
[Música]